[Music]
good afternoon my name is Lauren I'm
here with her Anya we are two engineers
on the firebase team at Google and today
we're excited to share with you how you
can integrate firebase into your
existing infrastructure so to start I
want to introduce you to firebase in
case you haven't used it already
firebase is Google's app development
platform we make it really easy to build
and ship your apps fast we support a
number of platforms like Android iOS web
and games and we are built on top of
Google cloud platform so you get all the
benefits of the global scalability of
Google cloud platform these are the
products that firebase offers we offer
things to help you build your apps
better and faster improve your apps
quality by monitoring them and grow your
app audience by being able to analyze
predict and send targeted messages there
are a few products we're using today in
our talk
so give you a brief introduction to each
of them the first one is firebase
authentication this is our solution for
managing users within your app there are
a number of Roth providers we support
like Google Facebook github and perhaps
most important for our presentation
today we also support custom
authentication where we can integrate
into your existing users store next do
we have a database solution called cloud
fire store this is one of the two
database solutions that firebase offers
and cloud firestore is a document based
database that's really great for real
time applications so if you're building
an app where you want the page to change
whenever the underlying data changes
without the user having to refresh the
page this is a great solution for you
now you might be thinking how do i how
do i make sure that only certain users
have access to the database and they
only have access to the parts that they
should be granted access
in two and that's where security rules
comes in and that's when we tied
together firebase authentication with a
database to allow fine-grained access
control for your apps users thirdly we
have cloud functions for firebase which
is our server list solution so you might
have heard about Google cloud functions
during this conference this is built
directly on top of Google cloud
functions with a set of firebase
specific tooling and cloud functions
allows you to respond to different
events happening in your app for example
an auth trigger allows you to lessen to
when a new user signed in a fire-- store
trigger allows you to lessen to when
data has been saved or you can lessen to
an analytics conversion event to know
once someone does something like
complete a purchase we support a number
of other and that providers like pups
but pub/sub other GCP triggers and other
firebase triggers now you might be
thinking that sounds great
but I'm working with legacy systems
users stores that already have existing
users and other databases that feat
might that fit my company's needs how do
i integrate those with firebase or maybe
I have ml models or other cloud services
and then dashboards tools that I want to
be building so ABS don't exist a nice
solution yours don't mine doesn't either
so how do you integrate firebase in a
seamless way with your existing
infrastructure and back-end systems
firebase solves many problems for you
it's a very large and versatile platform
but as Lauren pointed out firebase or
other mobile apps also often have
external integration requirements
firebase acknowledges this fact and
strives to make it a little easier for
it for you to integrate your existing
systems with firebase to that end we
provide a set of SDKs called admin SDK
is using which you can extend your
existing system so they can depend share
data with the private platform or
alternatively you
can use the API is that we provide so
your systems can directly talk to
firebase over HTTP the basic idea here
is that firebase helps you solve many
problems related to app development but
if you ever want to go beyond the
boundaries of the firebase platform and
bring in your own systems and own data
and API into the architecture firebase
supports that too so let's talk about
these different integration options
starting with the admin SDK many
firebase developers if you've ever
written any apps with firebase then you
should already be familiar with our
client SDKs available for platforms like
Android iOS web and unity administrators
are different from them in the sense
they are not designed to be integrated
or they are not designed to be directly
used by the end users of your app in
other words you would never deploy an
admin SDK on on your end users mobile
device or their web browser instead they
are meant to be used to build core
back-end services and administrative
tools for your apps because of this you
will also never deploy them you will
only deploy administer case in the
servers that you or your organization
owns and controls alternatively you can
deploy them in manage cloud environments
like Google cloud functions or app
engine where are you as the app
developer has control over the code
administer case are available in five
server-side programming languages as of
today and we will look at some of them
during the upcoming demos so speaking of
demos a lot of the pretty much all the
demos that we are going to look at today
are based on a little fun little movie
writing app that we built called fire
flicks I think it's very fitting since
we are literally sitting in a movie
theater so let's go to the let's go to
our demo machine and see what this looks
like
come it's built using our JavaScript SDK
and the view framework if you go to this
interface you will see some example
movies and some rating data all that
information
stored in Google on fire store we also
support several authentication schemes
including Google signing all of that is
made possible by firebase odd and this
live version of the app is coming to you
via firebase hosting today you can use
this interface to add some movie reviews
or add them to a personal collection for
easier lookup so this looks fairly
complete at this point but we are not
quite done in fact throughout the course
throughout the rest of the course of
this talk we will we are going to
implement several new use cases that
will require us to integrate what we
have today with a bunch of external
systems so let's go back to the slides
so other use cases we are going to
implement first we want to be able to
invite selected users to join the fire
flex platform and sort of become
moderators of the community we want to
be able to send out some emails
containing invitation codes to these
selected users and they should be able
to log in to fire flicks using those
invitation codes and when they do they
should automatically gain elevated
privileges in the app then we would want
to implement some new back-end services
to extend the capabilities of our app
but we would also want to make sure that
only specific users can actually consume
these external api's fire flicks also
supports self sign up so you can just go
to a website and self sign up using an
email address and a password for such
uses we would also want to run some kind
of e-mail verification flow so they
should get a link they can click and
confirm their email and we would want to
implement that using some kind of a
third-party email delivery service
something like SendGrid for example and
finally we want to keep track of the
movie movie relieves posted by the users
we want to encourage users to post but
at the same time you want to prevent
them from potentially spamming the
system with too much too many posts so
let's go through this use cases one by
one
and see how they are implemented
starting with let's begin with our
requirement for inviting selected users
to be moderators we would want to
obviously pre provision these user
accounts and grant them moderator all
ahead of time then we would want to be
able to send them or some invitation
codes but first let's talk about the
idea of roles and how its managed in a
in a platform like firebase in fire
flicks what we really want is the
ability to differentiate between two
classes of users say let's say regular
users and moderators regular users can
just sign up they can read most of the
data on the app and they post reviews
what's on the other hand are by
invitation only they have read access to
everything can do pretty much everything
a regular user can but they also have
access to certain privileged
capabilities like adding new movies now
in order to support and enforce rules
correctly you know apps such as fire
flicks we should be able to identify the
user's role both in the client code and
in also in the backend services the
client app depends on one of the easiest
way to do this in file a firebase
ecosystem is by using a technique called
custom claims it's built right into the
firebase earth flow so let's spend a
minute on figuring out how that actually
works when a firebase app kicks off the
sign-in flow it sends the users login
credentials to firebase off firebase
auth validates them and if everything
looks good
sends back an ID token refresh token
pair at this point the app is signed in
and it can use the ID token to call any
firebase backing services services like
file store the ID token is short-lived
it expires every hour at which point the
app can use the Refresh token to gain a
new ID token for the next hour now if
you build an app using one of our client
is decays it handles this entire flow
for you so you don't have to do anything
really it even takes care of automatic
refreshing of the ID token periodically
the ID token itself is just a JWT or a
JSON web token that contains some
metadata about the user encoded into it
it has a header a body and it is signed
by firebase also it cannot will be
forged now what custom claims gives us
is the ability to add our own custom
metadata such as rules into these items
you can use the admin SDK to permanently
associate some custom claims with a user
account and then whenever that user logs
into our app firebase odd will
automatically include those custom
claims in the users ID token and as you
can see once we get the roles encoded
into the users ID token then we can
validate those claims in various
components of a wrap to implement access
control for instance we can check for
users roles but in our own backing code
using the admin SDK there's also a way
to inspect claims we are fire basic
rules that enables you to implement
access control in your file store file
storage and firebase real-time database
API calls we will see examples of all
these techniques shortly but for now
let's go back to our original use case
of implementing a user immitation flow
our invitation flow should repeal a take
care of three things it should create
the account in firebase odd and grant it
the moderator role by setting some
custom then it should generate any
invitation code for the new user and
saved in some kind of a database or a
user store this wave in the use I
eventually logs in we have a verify the
ID our invitation code and finally it
should just email out the invitation
code to the user now there are several
different ways you can implement this
you probably have kind of a use of
provisioning flow in your organization
you can bake this into that or you can
build a new administrative tool to
handle this what we did was to basically
build out a little Python script using
the firebase Python admin SDK to handle
this entire flow so let's go to our demo
and see how it's implemented and then
see how it actually works
so I have a little Python script called
create PI create user dot PI and the one
of the first things I do in this script
is just importing the admin SDK and some
of its child modules and then I have a
function called run user imitation flow
which takes the email address of the
target user and runs the invitation flow
for that user so the first thing we do
is just initializing the admin SDK if
you've written any code using pretty
much any firebase SDK then the
initialize app API should should ring
some bells in your head once we have
initialized SDK we can use the old API
specifically specifically the create
user API to create a new user account in
firebase alt this returns an object
which contains the unique user ID that
firebase auth has assigned count and we
can use that user ID and pass it to the
set custom user claims API to set some
custom claims on the user account in
this case just one claim called
moderator equals true and then we have
some code here to generate an invitation
code for the user it's just a random
string that we generate we store all
this information in a collection called
in white sin cloud file store so we are
basically using cloud file stores of a
custom user database you can use any
database you like for this purpose and
finally we have a send invitation email
helper function which sends out this
email using a using a send grid API call
so let's try this out and see if it
actually works so I'm gonna run the
script locally on my machine and I'm
gonna invite Lauren to become a
moderator and moderator of fire flex so
this creates the moderator account
grants the permissions and sends out the
email at this point we can actually go
to firebase console and just search for
user account make sure it got created
yep there's the new user account is
created today minutes ago and we if we
go to our file store console we will
also see a new invitation for lower and
firebase at gmail.com now let's go back
to the demo the next step of this use
case is actually making it possible for
a user to log in using one of those
invitation codes that we just emailed
out now remember this is not a standard
authentication mechanism this is just
something that we are inventing so since
we invited Lauren I'm gonna invite her
back here to demonstrate how that part
is implemented great thanks for Anya so
I've just been invited and with the
Python script I should have gone an
email with a code and email combination
we will then in our app build a custom
authentication service to verify that
this code and email combination is valid
to do that we will be querying our
custom user store in this case is
actually just a cloud fire store
database but this could be substituted
with any number of user stores that
would be suitable for your application
after it verifies that code is valid it
then uses the firebase admin SDK to
generate a custom token send that back
to the client app the client app will
use it to login to the application with
firebase authentication so young what's
underpinning this flow is custom token
which is what's generated by the
firebase admin SDK this is what it might
look like you'll see that it is signed
by service accounts and the most
important information it contains is the
user ID or the UID for short and this
UID is what will map to the firebase
authentication user that gets created in
our project once I log in so to sign in
with a custom token is done through the
client app and we provide a method in
each of our client SDKs for them to be
able to sign in to firebase off with a
custom token and once
signing a curse they receive an ID token
in return and this is very similar to
signing in with another provider like a
Facebook or a github or a gmail sign-in
so let's see how that works in action so
we can switch to the demo please so here
I've got my email open and I see that
I've just been invited to join as a
moderator so here I have a code which I
will copy without triggering the
definition all right let's now try to
sign-in so I click on sign-in with code
with my email address and the code I
just copied click on submit it denna
asked me if I want to sync it with my
Google sign-in I don't want to do that
at the moment but as you can see I now
have a new tab called moderator that
just appeared so let's switch back to
the slides please so let's review what
just happened I got invited
I was emailed a code I then was able to
sign in to our custom event ocation
service and I'll show you that code in a
moment and that customer Thunder keishon
service then verifies that code with a
custom user store it then generates a
custom token with the firebase admin SDK
and the calling app receives that and
signs it in to firebase authentication
so if we can switch back to the demo
screen please
so our custom authentication service is
written and go and in this case we've
hosted on Google App Engine
but it could easily be hosted on your
own server or another cloud provider the
method that's interesting to us is
called authenticate and it is a method
that receives a couple of parameters so
we have the context of the request that
one
sent the email of the user that's trying
to sign in as a moderator the code that
they are using and this method is a
method off of an admin client so this is
a client that we've initialized with the
firebase admin SDK and go we first query
the user store for this email and code
combination and this user store returns
that user if it exists and if it does
then we get an error back and we throw
that error if it does exist we then use
the firebase admin client that we've
already initialized previously with the
auth service of the admin client and we
generate a custom token with the user ID
so we returned this custom token back to
the client and that's how the client was
able to sign in and verify that I was a
moderator if we can switch back to the
slides please so this is a great way to
integrate firebase with the existing
users store is that you might be using
like Active Directory or LDAP or
something custom now that we have
integrated some users and roles with our
app the next step would be to actually
go ahead and build out some some new
api's and new services to integrate our
app with but also implement some role
based access control on top of those
services specifically we would want to
make sure that only signed in users that
the users who have signed in to our web
app can access these api's or only the
signed in moderators can access this API
so now we already know that we can
identify an authenticated user by
looking at the ID token we also know
that we can inspect the custom claims in
those ID tokens to figure out what roles
they have so the easiest way to
implement access control in your own
back-end code is by just checking just
decoding the ID token and just checking
what's in there we get the user or the
client to send the ID token with every
back-end request we use the admin SDK to
verify the ID token
or additionally check for roles and then
if that check passes we can go ahead and
perform any of the privileged operations
the user wishes to perform on the server
so to demonstrate this functionality we
are going to build a new service that
enables fire flix users to tweet using
the official fire flix Twitter handle
but we want to make sure that only
authenticated moderators able to access
this endpoint we allow moderators to
create new movies in our database so
hopefully they can use this feature to
tweet about new additions so the way
this is going to be implemented is we
are going to put our back-end logic for
actually tweeting using the Twitter API
in a back-end server the the user will
call out to this end point using the
tweet that needs to be published along
with the ID token and then we will
verify it and if everything looks good
we'll call the Twitter API on behalf of
the user we implement this service in go
in fact it's going to be a simple
addition to the same go
application that Lauren demonstrated
earlier so it's running in Google App
Engine a moderator can call it from the
app and and get the twitter twitter api
invoked through that so let's go to our
demo machine again and see what the code
looks like the function that gets
triggered in this flow is called check
auth it receives the ID token of the
caller as an argument if you don't get
an ID tokens that means if a request
comes in without a valid ID token we
return an error immediately if not we go
ahead and call the verify ID token API
off the admin SDK this performs a series
of checks and if you till it actually
gives us a decoded represent of the ID
token and we can query that decoded
representation to check if it actually
has to moderate a claim in it if not
again we return an error now we wired up
our web web application in a way so that
all incoming requests first hit this
function and if it returns an error you
forget so gdb 401 unauthorized error
otherwise this code will actually go and
call the tutorial so let's see how this
code
actually works by first sending a couple
of fake requests so this is the end in
App Engine that we are gonna call first
I'm gonna call this without any ID token
error at all just trying to send us I'm
basically saying this hello world post
request so as we would expect me get ID
token not specified error which is the
error message that we return when
there's no ID token available
alternatively we can try to send a bogus
IP token header so I have this ID token
it's the custom header that our program
for but this is just a fake JWT
it just looks like an ID token but it's
really not so it fails to verify the
token signature as you would expect so
to get this check to pass we had to
actually call it as a moderator or I'm
gonna use this new to eat function tweet
something says to treat posted so
hopefully we can see it on the Twitter
right now there we go so let's go back
to our slides now we've been telling you
you can use the admin SDK to verify ID
tokens but we haven't really told you
what happens under the hood the check
performed by the admin SDK is actually
quite strong it checks for a number of
things like it has the correct signature
which is by far the most important thing
but it also said the token is not
expired but why that has to be checked
and also things like the token was
indeed issued against you a firebase
project not coming from some random
other firebase project and also this is
a fairly fast operation does not make
any RPC call so it is okay to do this
check for every incoming request now one
thing this API doesn't check for is
whether the ID token is revoked or not
our admin SDK is actually have a revoke
refresh tokens it will in insane
activity uses up to that point it's the
quick in now if you want to check if the
ID token has been revoked since it was
issued there's a separate API for that
in go it's called verify ID token and
check revoked but this actually does
make an API call so you order RPC call
so you do have to take that overhead
into account the other way you can
enforce roles and authorization in
firebase apps is by using firebase
security rules security rules are a
policy driven approach to intercept API
calls made by your clients to services
like files to cloud storage and real
time database and make sure that they
hear certain policies that you've
defined for example we have this file
security rule in place which is what
restricts the ability to create new move
only to moderators
so this rule applies to our movies
collection which is a collection we
actually have in our files to date
that's where all the moves are as you
can see we we give the right permission
to only use who contains the moderator
claim in their or token this regulators
from being a create or move emitter
moving on to our next use case which is
to be able to run an e-mail verification
flow for ourself sign up users we need
to be to basically send you some kind of
a verification link which they can
confirm their email address now
interestingly this is actually something
you can do just in the client-side using
of a client SDKs our client SDKs have
provided a send email verification if
you call it it's a good email
verification flow for you
however the email sent out by this API
they use a pre-configured set of email
templates and they also use a built in
email delivery service but if you're a
large enterprise you probably would want
to customize the content and layout of
this emails by including the company
logo and other branding information in
the emails that go out or you may have
your own email info for the kind of
things which you want to use so if you
want that kind of flexibility then you
should consider implementing this flow
using as another backend integration so
how are we going to do it we are going
to use cloud functions for piyah base we
are going to implement a plus for trick
every time you users finds up to fix and
inside this function we will use the no
js' SDK to generate an email
verification put it into a template of
our choosing and send out using a
third-party email delivery service
SendGrid
in this case so let's go to our demo
machine and let's look at what this
cloud function looks like
thank you so we have a cloud function
called send e-mail verification as you
can see this is implemented using the
file based functions SDK which is a set
of extensions that that are developed on
top of Google cloud functions so we have
on create trigger type which gets
triggered every time when you use a
signs up for our project this receives a
user record object that describes the
newly signed up user the first thing we
do is check whether this is actually a
password or a self sign up user with a
password because you see we have several
different ways users can sign up to our
app through Google sign-in or it could
be a user that we manually create using
our Python script so we have to first
filter those out so we have a little
check for that here what if he is a
password user then we go ahead and call
that - DK the specifically the generate
email verification link API which gives
us a URL link then we have this send
email help function which puts it into
our own template and send out sends it
out using using send grade so I'm gonna
go ahead and create a new account on our
web site I'm going to just log out the
existing session and go ahead and click
on sign up I'm just gonna use the same
email address but with a suffix and just
write the password there submit and that
will actually create the account and log
me in but as you can see the system
recognizes that it's an unverified user
account now if we now that event alone
should have triggered our cloud function
so we can go to the cloud functions
console or the logs in our project
hopefully we will see the new event here
147 that's about five seconds ago
so the link is already enroute we can
probably oh here we go so we now have a
verify email link sent out by our cloud
function we can use this link
to actually verify our user account okay
that's gonna
the system recognized me as a verified
user account because I've clicked on the
link let's go back to the slides so in
addition to generating e-mail
verification links our admin SDK is also
have api's for generating password reset
links and links for email signing you
can use these aps to further flesh out
your user management landscape and truly
integrate your existing systems more
deeply with firebase and firebase off
now what we just saw was just one
application of cloud functions and I'm
gonna invite Lauren back to show other
cool stuff you can do with functions
awesome thanks Ronnie yeah so sometimes
you might want to respond to critical
events happening in our application and
cloud functions is a great way of doing
that so the particular event we want to
respond to is when a user is posting too
many reviews too quickly so in other
words they're spamming the system and we
want a way to ban them and you can do
that with the firebase admin SDK
integrate it inside of a cloud function
you can prevent future logins and revoke
any existing refresh tokens
now you if you've been paying attention
you might remember an ID token last for
an hour so sometimes this could actually
take up to an hour what if we want to
ban our user right away and that's where
security rules comes in so you might
remember earlier I talked about how
firebase uses security rules to to allow
granular access control of database and
we do this based on the user ID of a
user within firebase authentication so
here we've got an example of a security
rule that you can write so we have a
function here called is blacklisted that
checks to see if that user ID is found
in the blacklist collection and
firestore and we then do a match rule
for the collection where our ratings are
stored to see if the user is in the
blacklist the users in the blacklist
then they are not allowed to write a
write a rating
we then also lockdown control to the
blacklist to make sure nobody can write
to it only a privileged environment like
a cloud function can make changes to a
blacklist
so let's see how all of that works so
here we've got our called functions code
and I'm going to just scroll down to our
function called update activity
indicators which is where all of this
happens so this is a firestore triggered
function it is triggered on rice - any
ratings so in other words when someone
has posted an e rating we first get the
user ID and this we get from the
parameter and within the database path
we then have a helper function that
checks this user ID to see if they've
been posting a lot of reviews in the
last little bit and see if we should ban
them so in our demo today we are
allowing two messages for every two
minutes and if users are posting more
than that then they will be banned if
should ban is true we will then update
the users user object in firebase
authentication to be disabled we will
also add them to the blacklist
collection and firestore remember this
is the collection we're checking for in
our security rules to see if the user is
able to do another rating and if we
don't end up needing to ban the user we
will reward them for their review by
incrementing their score so let's try to
see if I can trigger the blacklist so
here we've got some movies and I'm going
to just start writing some reviews so
I'm going to write a review for this one
a tattooed Interpol agent sounds like a
bad movie or if you actually like this
movie but I'm gonna raid it one star
alright let's see we've got this one oh
it's a cop movie and typically like hot
movies so we'll write that a four star
out of five
so I've now hit my Mac so the next one I
rate should trigger the blacklist so
let's do a review so I got an oh I get
this review submitted let's try to do
one more so I now I am banned from
submitting any more reviews as you can
see from this error message now that was
from the security security rules that we
just looked at let's see if I can log
out and log back in so I try to log in
again I see that my account has been
disabled by the administrator can we
switch back to the slides please so one
thing I do want to note is you should
not be deleting user accounts as a way
to ban them and the reason for that is
then they can just sign up again and
create a new account where is we
actually disable the account then that
prevents them from doing further
activity you seen that beam SDK is to do
all our external integrations but there
might be times where you would want to
implement an integration without an
administer Kay maybe your use case is
very simple and you feel like taking a
dependency on this PK is overkill or
maybe our programming in a language for
which the admin SDK is not available yet
whatever your reasons are firebase
strives to expose its services we our
rest whenever possible so you can access
them over good old HTTP so as our last
demo let's look at how to implement a
simple CLI tool that interacts with the
firebase real time database over rest
our objective is to build a ruby client
for displaying the top 10 most active
file 6 users we don't have an official
admin SDK for Ruby yet so this gives us
an excuse to use rest as for tracking
the most active users remember that we
already have a workflow implemented in
cloud functions that
demonstrated earlier which avoids users
points for their posts so the data we
are looking for is already stored in
real time database so now we are just
going to implement the the lower part of
this diagram we are of a CLI tool
securely queries for the most active
users and if you're wondering why we are
using real-time database for this last
demo it's because the REST API for
real-time database actually supports
richer queries at the moment than
firestore does
so all firebase and GCP rest api is
support OAuth 2 so we need to include an
oath to bear token in all the requests
we make the easiest way to do this is by
using one of the official Google auth
libraries which are available in about
seven different programming languages
that's what we are going to do but if
you feel that's too heavy wait you can
also code the OAuth flow yourselves just
a standard odd flow in general if you
google its account or a refresh token
you can always exchange that for a valid
or two token so let's go to our demo
again look at what our Ruby code it's
been a while since I it will be code so
the first thing we do is just require
the Google auth ruby gem and then we
have some code here to just initialize
it out using a Google application
default credentials and this is the URL
that we are going to make the rest call
on it's basically just direct URL to the
real time database and we are all
requesting for the requesting it to
order all the data by the all the users
by their score and give me the ten last
of the ten highest scores in the
database and then we basically have a
big loop here which periodically makes
the same rest API call some code here to
actually apply the authorization header
to the outgoing requests and some code
to parse the JSON response coming from
real time database and show it in a nice
little
CLI weave so let's quickly try it out so
here are some fake data that's coming
from from our database we didn't want to
put you we didn't want to make sure we
want to make sure that you
my email doesn't accidentally appear
here it was people there and Sam's turn
for some reason who's a dev rel for
firebase just to make sure that it's
working as intended I'm gonna go and
just update some data manually and see
if it gets picked up we have database
right now Steven Spielberg has 2,000
points I'm gonna boost his point by a
factor of 10 and yeah so you can see it
gets jumps up to the top right away
let's go back to our demo slides so
real-time database is certainly not the
only firebase product for which there's
REST API in fact we are increasingly
opening up our products for restful
integrations this is just a partial list
of what's available today and the nice
thing is the way you authorize requests
for all this API is identical to what we
demonstrated today if you know how to
integrate with one REST API you can
pretty much use any of these other SJP
eyes as well now we are approaching the
end of our talk we've been looking at a
lot of a lot of code a lot of demos in
the last 50 minutes or so so it's a good
time to take a step back and just take
the bird's eye view of everything we've
developed so far we started out with a
fairly straightforward firebase app that
uses fibers auth and cloud files to a
server database then we implemented the
little Python script to create new user
accounts in firebase auth and grant them
the moderator role by setting some
custom claims the same script also
handles generating mutation codes and
saving them into a database then we
implemented a little go App Engine
endpoint that allows users to log in to
file flex using the invitation codes
they receive over email we added a
second endpoint to that same go
application which receives the ID token
of the caller verifies it and if it's
coming from a moderator calls out to a
another external API Twitter in this
case to publish some twist tweets
then we implemented a custom email
verification flow using cloud functions
for firebase
we implemented the service function that
gets triggered every time when you use a
signs up there is the node.js
admin SDK to generate email verification
links and send them out then we looked
at a second cloud function that gets
triggered for every movie review posted
by a user we use it to track
spammer spamming behavior and
potentially band the band such uses from
the system we disabled their user
accounts in firebase auth and use
firebase security rules to cut off the
immediate access to to our database and
finally we implemented a little Ruby CLI
tool to securely query our real-time
database over rest now this is certainly
a lot of moving parts implemented in
several different about 4 different
languages your application architecture
is probably not as complex or
distributed at least maybe not yet but
the point we are trying to make is that
if you want to build something more
advanced and sophisticated using
firebase you certainly can you can start
simple like we did with just one or two
firebase services and then incrementally
bring you existing systems API send data
into the architecture and try to stay
ahead of your changing requirements you
can use things like the admin SDK REST
API sand cloud functions to bridge
different components and make sure that
you use the same users roles and data
both in firebase and everywhere else
Laura so in conclusion
firebase is a development platform it
allows you to build your apps monitor
their performance and grow your user
base and we can integrate with your
existing systems whether they are on
Prem or with another cloud provider and
there's too many ways you do that one is
by using the firebase admin SDK we used
that SDK in several languages today and
you can also use the REST API switch you
can call within your server or any
server and lastly we also demonstrated
how you can use cloud functions as a
glue between different servers
and also as a way to respond to critical
events happening in your app all of our
SDKs including the firebase admin SDKs
are open source so we invite you to be
part of our community to file bug
reports contribute and give us your
feature request
[Music]